all right I hereby submit this as
definitive proof that megapixel counts
in smartphone cameras does not matter so
we did a super scientific test of the
best 16 smartphone cameras that came out
in the last calendar year and it was a
side by side blind voting test you can
see for yourself still at
vote.mkbhd.com so 20 plus million votes
later the overall winner spoiler alert
was the 12 megapixel pixel 6A of course
dispelling quickly that you have to have
the most expensive one to win but also
take a look at this this is a chart for
votes per megapixel and what you'll
notice is not only do the 12 megapixel
cameras all bubble to the top but
there's a lot of roughly 50 megapixels
in the middle and the worst performing
phone here was the 200 megapixel Moto
Edge 30 Ultra so I mean really it's just
math clearly doubling your megapixel
count does not get anywhere near
doubling the quality of your photo so
honestly at this point my spicy hot take
is you should just ignore the megapixel
count in smartphone cameras entirely
unless it's something weird like two
megapixels or something